[Музика]
Привіт, мене звуть Ольга Мінман, ласкаво просимо на
наш постійний пост із зображенням татуювання у стилі уроку англійської мови,
чи ви коли-небудь думали, як ці
слова пов'язані,
коли-небудь замислювалися, які татуювання в
Інтернеті є спільним у соціальному житті та безпосередньому житті
кожного разу, коли ви використовуєте  Інтернет ви
відстежуєте своє особисте життя ваше приватне
життя всі ваші дії та
інтереси ваше місцезнаходження ваше ваше
настрій вашого життя і не
любите ділитися публікацією поставити
лайк  татуювання, але пам'ятайте, що
воно постійне і дуже
важко витрачає багато енергії, щоб
позбутися від нього,
я б назвав це електронним татуюванням
ваше соціальне життя в Інтернеті
електронне татуювання
- це цифровий відбиток, який ви залишаєте
назавжди щоразу, коли публікуєте в Instagram
тик-так facebook кожен  Коли ви використовуєте
GPS або перевіряєте в новому місці,
ми дізнаємося правила,
як це працює, як бути обережним
і як уникнути великих помилок
під час користування  g internet Я хотів би
поділитися з вами дуже цікавим текстом,
текстом, створеним спеціально для
підлітків у всьому світі,
ви, хлопці, є найбільшими користувачами
Інтернет-
соціальних мереж, є правила, яких слід дотримуватися,
хоча
давайте прочитаємо це ваше цифрове татуювання,
перш ніж перейти до  текст, давайте
подивимося на корисну лексику,
деякі слова, які ви, можливо, знайомі
, деякі з них були б для вас новими,
я пропоную вам взяти аркуш паперу та
олівець,
щоб вести записи нових
ідей словника
та робити  вправи після
тексту
давайте зіставимо слова зі значенням
я прочитаю слова в лівій колонці
складний слід рекрутер
деталізує, щоб відмовитися від функції,
щоб виявити придатне
, подивіться на слова в правому
стовпці
та знайдіть слова, які б  але
синоніми, звичайно,
[Музика]
дійсно
пишуть слово комплекс, його синонім
буде
складним слідом або слідом
рекрутер або роботодавець, тому роботодавець —
це людина, яка про  дає вам роботу,
і як тільки ви влаштовуєтеся на роботу, ви стаєте
працівником
деталі або інформація, яку легко
відмовитися від красивого синоніма до
слова
залишити функцію або мету,
щоб розкрити або показати
і, нарешті, підходить або
доречно, зараз ви побачите  текст, який
я збираюся прочитати, будь ласка, дотримуйтесь його,
якщо ви дивитеся урок на YouTube, ви
, звичайно, можете призупинити його
і прочитати його самі, просто слідуйте за мною,
читаючи текст,
ваше цифрове татуювання
щоразу, коли ви йдете в Інтернет, ви залишаєте
слід, це просто  як справжній слід,
він показує, де ви були, як довго
ви залишалися
і що ви там робили щоразу,
коли ви реєструєтесь в онлайн-сервісі,
надсилайте електронний лист, завантажуйте відео,
завантажуйте фотографію, доступ до інформації
та ваш цифровий
слід  виявив, що
це не повинно викликати занепокоєння,
але доцільно знати про свій
цифровий слід
і бути обережним і розумним, коли ви
в мережі,
шість основних порад щодо піклування про свій
цифровий слід
Не забувайте виходити з системи, коли ви залишаєте
веб-сайт,
особливо якщо ви використовуєте спільний
комп’ютер,
якщо ви цього не робите, хтось може
легко прикинутися вами
двома, не повідомляйте нікому свої паролі
та не записуйте їх у  очевидне
місце
робить їх складнішими, використовуючи
комбінацію букв,
цифр і розділових знаків
три, щоб сказати дорослому, якщо ви зустрінете
щось в Інтернеті, що викликає у вас
тривогу або занепокоєння
, є способи повідомити про невідповідний
або образливий вміст,
і в більшості випадків веб-менеджери швидко реагують
4. запам'ятайте свої улюблені веб-сайти за
допомогою кнопки історії
та функції закладки на вашому
комп'ютері або мобільному пристрої.
Це спосіб, за допомогою якого ваш цифровий
слід може працювати на вашу користь,
але не забувайте регулярно очищати історію свого веб-переглядача
п'ять, якщо ви хочете залишати коментарі в Інтернеті
вам не потрібно використовувати своє власне ім’я,
придумайте псевдонім, щоб використовувати замість нього, ви
також можете використовувати зображення
замість справжньої фотографії
6. захищайте свою особистість в Інтернеті
будьте обережні аб  дізнайтеся, з ким ви ділитеся особистою
інформацією, і
завжди подумайте двічі, перш ніж ділитися
такими деталями, як ваша
домашня адреса школи або номер телефону з
кимось.
Подумайте про майбутнє. Усі види
людей цікавляться вашим цифровим
слідом
, зараз коледжі,
університети та роботодавці досить часто
перевірте онлайн-профілі можливих
кандидатів
у рамках їхнього процесу подачі заявок.
Є випадки, коли люди не
пропускали роботу
та місця в коледжах, тому що їх
цифровий слід не вразив
рекрутерів,
тому пам’ятайте, бережіть себе, не кладіть занадто багато
особисту інформацію в Інтернеті
і завжди ретельно подумайте, перш ніж
щось публікувати,
запитайте себе, чи був би я радий, щоб
усі сказали це
добре, я сподіваюся, що ви запам'ятаєте
всі шість основних
правил безпеки в Інтернеті, давайте перейдемо до деяких
вправ,
виберіть правильний варіант для виконання
речення
знову запам’ятовуються, якщо ви дивитеся його онлайн,
ви завжди можете повернутися до тексту,
і я пропоную  ви роздруковуєте його та
маєте перед собою під час виконання
вправ,
коли ви переходите в Інтернет, ви можете зробити
наступне; ви
можете вибрати, яка інформація про вас буде записана,
залишити слід, що показує, де ви були
і що ви робили,
або надіслати  інформацію для рекрутерів,
звичайно, оскільки ми прочитали її з тексту,
ви залишаєте сліди того, що ви робили
, це правильна відповідь,
якщо люди шукають інформацію про вас,
вони можуть
давайте подивимося на варіанти, які
вони можуть знайти паролі ваших веб-сайтів із закладками
або цифровий слід
правильно цифровий слід – це
правильна відповідь,
яка включатиме все, що згадано
вище,
хтось може видаватися за вас, якщо ви
не виходите з системи,
коли залишаєте сайт,
публікуючи коментар або публікуючи фотографію,
залишаючи сайт, є правильною відповіддю
або
життя  синонім, який ми бачили
раніше,
давайте перейдемо далі, ви повинні зробити ваші
паролі важко вгадати
, використовуючи всі великі літери, що
робить їх складними, включаючи
символ текст s  uggests ускладнюють його
, використовуючи як
знаки пунктуації, так і символи,
якщо користувач повідомляє про невідповідний вміст,
зверніть увагу на слово «невідповідний»,
префікс
у додає негативне значення цьому слову,
тому ми мали відповідне й тепер
невідповідне
правильне веб-менеджери зазвичай реагують
негайно,
рекрутери часто відповідають  інші користувачі
хочуть прочитати те, що вони сказали
так, правильна відповідь: веб-менеджери
зазвичай реагують негайно,
тому не поспішайте повідомити, що
ви повинні повідомляти про образливі зауваження в
Інтернеті,
якщо ви вважаєте, що вони дійсно
серйозні,
у всіх випадках, якщо ви можете знайти  зв’яжіться
та встигніть,
коли текст говорить нам про це в усіх
випадках,
коли ви вважаєте це образливим,
а порада щодо запам’ятовування ваших
улюблених веб-сайтів полягала в тому, що
ви можете використовувати браузер, функцію закладки
або мобільний пристрій,
так, функція закладки
допоможе вам зберегти  всі ваші
інтереси
гарні, зараз ми повернемося до тексту,
і я хотів би, щоб ви прочитали його ще раз на
y  наші власні,
оскільки ми знову проведемо читання публікацій
[Музика]
правильно, давайте  перевірте, чи були ви
уважні
та уважні, коли читали текст, зараз
на екрані
ви побачите список усіх
пропозицій,
давайте згрупуємо їх у поради щодо того, що
нам робити,
а що не слід робити під час користування
Інтернетом
[Музика]
правильно  все переплуталося, давайте виправимо
їх разом.
Ви можете використовувати зображення замість своєї
фотографії.
Мовчіть про невідповідний контакт, на
який ви зіткнулися,
виходячи з веб-сайту,
забудьте стерти історію свого веб-переглядача,
напишіть свій пароль там, де ви
можна легко знайти,
використовувати розділові знаки у ваших паролях,
скористайтеся кнопкою історії, щоб знайти
улюблений веб-сайт,
і використовуйте своє ім'я, коли публікуєте коментарі в
Інтернеті
прямо зараз, будь ласка, використовуйте аркуш паперу
та олівець,
щоб згрупувати всі ці пропозиції в
до і  не
[Музика  ]
[Музика]
[Музика
] добре, давайте подумаємо, що ми маємо робити,
коли пишемо в Інтернеті,
використовувати зображення замість себе фотографію
гарна
ідея вийти, коли ви залишаєте веб-сайт,
використовуйте розділові знаки в паролі,
використовуйте кнопку історії, щоб знайти улюблений
веб-сайт
і тепер це не дуже важливо,
мовчіть про невідповідний вміст, на
який ви стикаєтесь,
забудьте стерти історію свого веб-переглядача,
запишіть свій пароль у місці, де ви
можете легко знайти його,
використовуйте своє ім'я, коли публікуєте коментарі в
Інтернеті,
я знаю більшість своїх  студенти – це
підлітки,
я теж був підлітком, одного дня
я знаю, що
ви легко татуєтеся, а також
соціальні мережі в Інтернеті на всіх своїх пристроях,
але пам’ятайте, як я вже згадував на
початку,
це легко зробити
разом  опублікуйте повідомлення, як реєстрацію,
поділитеся фотографією, а також запропонуйте
зробити це двом,
але це триває вічно, і дуже
важко позбутися
зайвих роздумів, як бути в Інтернеті, так
і відвідувати тату-салон  Я буду
дуже радий,
щоб усі побачили це.
Я не шкодую про свої татуювання сьогодні,
вони триватимуть лише пару
годин, я можу легко це змити,
або я зможу змити свій
цифровий відбиток, про мої цифрові татуювання в
Інтернеті
ніколи не дізнаються  дякую за сьогоднішній
урок
і побачимось наступного разу
[Музика]
до побачення